[Musique]
étranger
étranger [
Musique]
la forme du corps est longuement étirée c'est
autour
de la tête ressemble à un chien ce
que vous pouvez aussi voir c'est qu'il a de
très petits yeux et un gros nez donc
c'était très agressif parce qu'il pouvait  je ne
vois pas bien
il attaque toujours ici et il saute
dans les airs jusqu'à 15 pieds ou
plus
avec des pattes courtes et des ailes courtes et un
visage et des dents effrayants effrayants
il ressemble à un dragon
il peut aussi voler
vous devez être très prudent
surtout  quand il a faim,
c'est tellement toxique que même son haleine
peut tuer
[Musique]
ouais une fois que la lueur du feu j'ai
détruit notre ville
[Musique]
donc si vous êtes attaqué, vous feriez mieux
de courir
[Musique]
déjà
des crocodiles sont trouvés ou  le président est
[Musique]
En fait, je crois vraiment que les gens
qui voient des choses étranges et des
créatures étranges voient ce qu'ils voient,
alors les gens qui voient un étrange type de
reptile ou qui croient avoir vu un
étrange type de reptile feraient  ont
rapporté jusqu'aux années 1930 qu'ils avaient
vu un tatsun où il y avait
des reportages réguliers sur les médiums des
blessures de tatouage et où des magazines scientifiques
demandaient à leurs lecteurs d'envoyer leurs
observations de salles de tatsule pour analyse
pour les zoologistes
l'idée qu'il y a de grands reptiles
de serpentine  ou la forme de lézard existe dans
toute l'Europe et vous avez un
terme général qui est Dragon qui vient du
mot grec draco qui signifie serpent
le mot germanique pour qui est charpie chaude
ou serpent serpent
um réellement traduit et où que vous
alliez en Allemagne ou en allemand  dans certaines
parties de l'Europe, vous avez des noms différents
pour le dragon et l'un d'entre eux est Turtle
War
[Musique]
dragons
abordables
[Musique]
imaginez dans les temps anciens
non seulement au moyen âge mais aussi
jusqu'à la fin du 19ème
siècle
la nature à cette époque était  encore quelque chose de
dangereux quelque chose de très étrange
qui
est
quelque chose contre les êtres humains
[Musique]
mais néanmoins les gens devaient marcher d'
un endroit à l'autre errant d'
une vallée à l'autre Traverser des
montagnes et de cette façon
errer seul Je pouvais imaginer qu'ils se
contactaient  tout à coup avec une telle créature
et le cas le plus intéressant était pour
moi c'était en 1899 quand un
forestier officiel en
Autriche a rapporté qu'il avait été
attaqué par une salle de tortue dans un
manteau de fourrure très lisse
le kadu qui est un vers
est
[Musique]
[  Musique]
étrangère
[Musique]
depuis ma plus tendre enfance je
m'intéresse à la cryptosologie qui est un
mot grec signifiant les
signes d'animaux cachés animaux encore
non découverts par
la zoologie
et alors que la plupart des cryptosologues
s'intéressent à savoir si ces animaux sont
réels ou non ou  essayez de les chasser, je suis plus
intéressé par les implications sociologiques et
folkloriques de ces rapports
alors que dans toute l'Europe, vous trouvez le mythe
selon lequel il y avait des dragons dans les temps anciens
et il existe de nombreux termes et noms pour
ces dragons en Allemagne, le dragon était
souvent appelé  lint womb qui est un vieux
mot allemand lien signifie serpent et un
moyen d'arriver aussi donc c'est lindworm se
traduit en fait par serpent serpent
dans la région alpine le lymphome était
souvent appelé tatsule qui est l'un des
nombreux noms locaux d'autres sont
des backstruts mobiles australiens chauds Hazel worm
ou en Italie basilic
ly quelque chose est des
observations nutritionnelles des salles de tortues, c'est-à-dire
des gens qui prétendent avoir vu une
créature ressemblant à un dragon dans les montagnes
se répandre dans toutes les Alpes de
Nice en France
à l'Italie autour des grands italiens
aime
partout  La Suisse, l'Autriche, des parties de
l'Allemagne et de la Bavière, et cela descend également
jusqu'en Yougoslavie, où il existe à nouveau des
variantes locales.
vous auriez pu voir
le lien en général, les gens ont tendance à
penser que la salle des tortues est un animal
qui vit dans les rochers au-dessus de la limite des arbres,
mais de toutes les histoires que j'ai
rassemblées,
près de la moitié des histoires faisant référence
à l'ASL enroulée près ou dans  l'eau
où pratiquement aucune observation de
vers de tortue dans la forêt,
donc généralement
où les gens s'attendent à voir des utérus de tortues
ou où les gens voient toucher les pièces, c'est là
où les gens diraient des lézards normaux
ainsi que l'Allemagne a été déboisée et
s'est installée plus le dragon a été poussé
aux marges géographiques de la
région et celle où les lacs d'
une part et les hautes montagnes de l'
autre
[Musique]
les observations les plus récentes de
créatures ressemblant à des tatsuworm ont eu lieu dans la zone
des grands lacs italiens
qui se trouvent autour du lac de Côme  Garda et le
lac Marjora et dans le sud de Tyrone au
bord j'ai fait Chevalier
et en Vénétie qui est la province
de Venise en Italie les parties alpines de
cette province et en Autriche dans la
vallée des extrémités donc si quelqu'un cherche de
vrais utérus de tortues vivantes il  devrait
concentrer les recherches il y a
[Musique]
étrangère
a été trouvé au 14ème siècle
c'est Saint Michael's au tolfeld
um aux dragons la soi-disant fosse aux dragons
au 13ème siècle le sceau de la ville de
klagenfoot montrait déjà un ailé
dragon
le lindworm
[Musique]
est étranger
étranger [
Musique] [
Musique]
existence [
est un mot allemand qui se traduit en
anglais par un serpent avec des pattes qui
vous donne généralement une bonne idée de l'
apparence d'un tatsulum  comme
les gens qui les voient en ont parlé de nombreuses
sortes différentes mais généralement c'est
soit un gros lézard comme un iguane ou
un serpent et il y a eu des rapports de
salles de taxi sans jambes donc des
serpents complets ou seulement des pattes avant ou seulement des
pattes arrière ou même avec un  rangée de pattes comme un
mille-pattes
étranger
[La musique]
ressemble souvent généralement à un lézard mais
avec une queue trapue, donc comme si la queue
était coupée, la peau ressemble à celle d'un
lézard ou d'un triton, mais il y a beaucoup d'
observations chaudes de Tatsu qui disent que c'est
celui que j'ai vu avait généralement un cheveu
dans les rapports modernes qui sont
plus crédibles en termes zoologiques, on
dit que la tête ressemble à celle d'un triton
ou d'un serpent ou d'un lézard, mais il y a environ 200
ans, cette chambre d'Hudson était toujours
quand les gens rapportaient  blessures totales, ils ont
dit qu'il avait la tête d'un mammifère, donc
principalement une tête de chat ou une tête de chèvre ou
une tête de chien ou même une tête d'enfant
[Musique]
l'histoire est que le ver à charpie vivait à
clangford
et que les gens vivent à l'extérieur de clanford
parce qu'ils avaient peur du lindworm
et celui de Tesla vivait dans cette
zone
donc surtout la femme ils avaient
beaucoup peur quand nous étions plus jeunes nous quand
nous avons entendu l'histoire nous avions un peu
peur du ver de charpie parce que quand il
avait faim il a aussi mangé parfois
une des gentilles filles je pensais que le
lindrom pouvait me mordre et me manger
et puis l'homme vient des
petits villages aux alentours
et un jour le prince de clangford
a construit une tour
où les jeunes chevaliers pourraient se battre contre
la charpie et l'un des fermiers il
avait
un boeuf un boeuf fort
et ils ont mis quelque chose dans sa bouche comme
un quand tu vas à la pêche
non seulement lire des livres sur les journaux
et collecter des informations sur ces monstres,
mais je voyage également dans de nombreuses régions où
des monstres ont été vus, où
des salles d'église ont été vues et j'ai passé
des vacances en Italie où
les Italiens aiment les salles de Tatsu ont été
bien signalés  jusqu'à il y a cinq ans
et euh traversé les montagnes, mais
même si j'ai trouvé d'anciens rapports, je n'ai jamais été
capable d'en photographier un moi-même
l'une des choses les plus intéressantes que
j'ai remarquées est en revanche de dire que les
serpents de mer sont comme des monstres un grand
pourcentage de  les rapports font référence à des
animaux morts, soit environ 60 rapports sur 500
font référence à la découverte d'un squelette ou
en fait à la mort d'un ver de tatouage,
mais le plus récent sur lequel j'ai enquêté
était le cas d'un Tatsu qui a été
tué dans les années 1980 à  Carlton dans le Tyrol du Sud
où un fermier a trouvé une chambre Tatsu
qui était morte et parce qu'il l'avait écrasée
sur son tracteur
et cela a été collecté et
analysé plus tard par un zoologiste et s'est avéré
être un abri pusek c'est un lézard sans pattes
qui vit dans les Balkans  dans ce qui
était la Yougoslavie c'était très proche d'
une voie ferrée donc on soupçonnait que
ce
lézard des Balkans qui ressemble à un serpent
créature très étrange et grande
a rampé sur un wagon de chemin de fer dans les
Balkans puis
s'est éteint quand le train s'est arrêté à Saint
Joseph à Carlton
et a donc été tué il y a
[Musique]
étranger
[Musique] [
Musique]
garder des animaux exotiques qui s'échappent ou
qui sont relâchés dans la nature il
y a certainement plus de chance que de vrais
animaux soient derrière certaines des
observations mais généralement je le fais  pense que
c'est
toujours une question de perception
autour de l'année 1800 vous avez des
métiers à tisser tactiles de trois mètres en règle générale et 1930 vous
avez des utérus d'un pied en règle générale et
je pense que c'est une confirmation très forte
de l'idée que tant que
les Alpes  comme un habitat était pratiquement
intact par un homme, il pouvait imaginer de
grandes créatures y vivant comme dans
des pays étrangers autant que les
montagnes étaient explorées par les alpinistes
par les touristes,
l'idée d'un dragon de trois mètres vivant
autour du lac de Côme est devenue incroyable,
alors les gens avaient tendance à voir  plus petits animaux
[Musique]
étranger [
Musique]
[Musique]
le nom Arkansas
est le thème que nous avons décidé de montrer à notre
public avec environ 150 espèces et plus
de 2 000 individus
nous
exposons sur nos terrains la plus grande
collection de la faune alpine  dans le
monde
bien dans la mesure où je suis un scientifique naturel
et surtout et intéressé par le comportement animal
je crois en ce que je vois et ce que je sais
l'histoire du ventre de tortue est intéressante
mais c'est pour moi c'est un mythe c'est une
légende
et je pourrais  imaginez que nous avons une contrepartie
biologique très basique
au ver de combat qui est
l'autel de la rivière que l'
auteur de la rivière vit principalement comme son
nom l'indique sur les rivières et les ruisseaux et
les étangs
est plus ou moins
nocturne ou actif pendant l'obscurité
et son comportement me donne le  impression
qu'il s'agit de la
figure réaliste de la salle des tortues
la loutre de rivière lève son corps pour
avoir une vue d'ensemble il
crie si quelque chose lui fait peur elle
siffle aussi si elle a peur et
lorsqu'elle nage en
plongeant et si pendant la parade nuptiale
Comportement d'un mâle  en suivant la femelle,
cela donne l'impression d'un steak
et donc tous ensemble ce comportement de l'
autel de la rivière
pourrait être une très bonne
image
pour l'idée d'une tortue
[Musique]
Riviera
différent [
Musique]
important
[Musique]
personnes de la  pays où ils erraient
Traversant des montagnes
ou parfois très isolés seuls la
nuit dans les Ténèbres
et à cette époque
même au 19ème siècle la
nature était quelque chose d'étrange dangereux
c'était quelque chose dont il fallait avoir peur
et
River Auto en fait n'est pas seulement
River vivant dans les rivières mais  ou dans l'eau
mais il erre aussi d'une Vallée
à l'autre alors Traversant des montagnes
il se peut que l'eau de la rivière
croise le chemin d'un homme errant
étranger
[Musique]
il il pourrait te mordre s'il est s'il a
peur s'il est dedans  un coin ne peut pas
s'échapper il vous attaquera il
vous mordra il criera donc cet animal, je
pense,
montre beaucoup d'objets
qui appartiennent au
soi-disant ver de combat et le cas le plus
intéressant était pour moi en
1899 quand un fonctionnaire  Forester en
Autriche a rapporté qu'il avait été
attaqué par un tutsalom dans un
manteau de fourrure très lisse et les tests ont été faits pour et
il crachait du poison sur lui et il
l'a frappé et l'a tué et quand plus tard
les scientifiques sont venus le récupérer c'était le
pêcheur de  un cerf
donc
pratiquement tout pourrait être transformé
en salle de tatouage si la peur ou l'
idée que cet animal existait
euh était considérée comme réelle, tout
pouvait se transformer en observation de tatouage
[Musique] Il
y a 500 ans,
chaque os et chaque crâne que les gens trouvaient
pensaient  c'est qu'il est lié à
des dragons ou à des créatures mythiques
étrangères au
soi-disant lidworm qui
n'est bien sûr pas une créature mystique mais c'est
de l'ère glaciaire et c'est un rhinocéros laineux
donc euh à l'époque où ils ont trouvé la
créature
ils le pensaient  serait autre chose
parce qu'ils ne connaissent pas les dinosaures
et les robinets, mais après cela, en
1840, le paléontologue est venu dans la
ville de klangford et a vu le crâne,
puis il a découvert que c'était le
rhinocéros laineux de la dernière période glaciaire.  il a
environ 30 000 ans peut-être un peu
plus vieux mais nous pensons à environ 30 000 ans
et ce que vous pouvez voir clairement ici sur les
sites et ici aussi que c'est vraiment une
structure osseuse
si vous vous cassez un os aujourd'hui c'est la même
structure aussi quand vous regardez  là-dessus, vous
pouvez entendre qu'il y a plus un os de neige,
c'est une sollicitation de graisse bien sûr, il
ne vit pas sur le bouclier de glace mais il
vit autour des zones vitrées
avec les mammifères mais ce n'était pas si
fréquent mais vous pouvez aussi voir est  qu'il
a de très petits yeux et un gros nez et
à cause de ces faits ils pensent que le
site était mauvais mais l'odeur était bonne donc
c'était très agressif car il
ne pouvait pas bien voir quand les gens de
clagafort ont trouvé cette vache ils n'ont vu que
le  partie supérieure parce que la mâchoire inférieure
est manquante, donc elle ressemble beaucoup plus à un
serpent qu'à tout le reste, elle est également
très grande et n'a aucune similitude avec
d'autres animaux de nos jours en tant que
paléontologue et avec nos connaissances, nous
savons que c'est un rhinocéros si vous êtes
aller en Afrique et regarder les Winans
aujourd'hui, ils ont un Sumatra, ils sont très
similaires et ils sont
euh, ils sont liés, donc il ne fait aucun
doute qu'il s'agit d'un vinyle et non d'un
linful
comme exemple de la façon dont ce processus pourrait
fonctionner si vous visitez Lochness  et voyez une
grande ombre sombre dans les vagues, même si
vous êtes sceptique, vous penseriez
en termes de monstre du Loch Ness, les gens
ont des idées préconçues sur ce qu'ils
savent des médias et au cours des
siècles précédents, nous savions à travers le folklore
sur quoi  attendez-vous en termes de
monstres
et il y a un canal Tendances pour que
les monstres soient à la marge de la
civilisation qui est une lance de dragon
signalée en Allemagne partout
au Moyen Âge, personne n'en avait jamais vu,
mais on savait que des dragons y vivaient
et autant que l'Allemagne est devenue déboisée
et  sédentarisé plus le dragon était
poussé aux marges géographiques de
la région et là où les lacs d'
une part et les hautes montagnes
d'autre part et dans les Alpes cette idée
du Dragon a pu survivre le
plus longtemps
je pense que le la  les gens qui ont trouvé le
crâne au 14ème siècle ont vraiment
cru à la légende du lindworm
parce qu'ils ne savaient pas que c'était un
crâne de l'ère glaciaire d'un mammifère de
l'ère glaciaire
eh bien je dirais que les habitants de
klagenforth étaient déçus  ce
fait pour la première fois mais de toute façon le
crâne est venu au 1849 a fondé un
musée régional d'histoire naturelle et
plus tard au musée régional de
Corinthe où vous pouvez toujours le voir
étranger
[Musique] [
Musique]
étranger
[Musique]
nourriture que nous avons  environ 100 000 habitants
un peu moins et nous voici sur la
place principale c'est le nouveau Square neuya Platz
en allemand et derrière nous on peut le voir dans la
salle Lind qui est le symbole de notre ville
nous avons tous un lien fort avec le
droit Lindbergh  ici
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
donc le lindworm ouais ce n'est pas si facile de
définir ce que c'est en fait tout le monde
dit que c'est un dragon que si vous allez
plus loin vous verrez que le visage est
proche de craindre le merveilleux lion alors
vous pouvez voir le  les oreilles c'est comme un oiseau
à la fin la queue est comme celle d'un
serpent et elle a été construite au 16ème
siècle la grande statue d'Hercule a
été ajoutée au 17ème siècle c'est un
Orient étranger
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
étranger
Allemagne
[Musique] [
Musique]
le Monument du lindworm à
la nouvelle place de clarkford est un
fait intéressant c'est environ six villes
et il montre le lindworm avec cette
bouche ouverte et de la bouche sort une
fontaine
donc c'est très artistique et quand on
regarde la queue La queue torsadée
du lindworm c'est aussi un signe pour
un grand maître en sculpture
[Musique]
cette fontaine était aussi une
chose pratique elle était utilisée pour l'
approvisionnement en eau  dans la ville,
donc l'ensemble est un
signe très caractéristique du maniérisme romain
c'est une œuvre d'art très importante
quand nous sommes petits enfants chaque classe
va à la salle des peluches et la regarde et nous avons
appris l'histoire du lindworm à
l'école
et  oui je pense que pour les citoyens de
Langford c'est aussi un symbole important
car c'est le symbole de notre ville
donc les gens
doivent choisir ce qu'ils veulent voir en
premier mais la plupart d'entre eux vont
d'abord sur la nouvelle place où nous avons
notre bombe Tesla  et puis la récitation nous
allons nous baigner nous allons dans un
musée nous allons faire du shopping ou
regardons où nous devons où nous
pouvons acheter un souvenir avec le bureau d'information Tesla one
étranger
[Music]
et vous pouvez voir un  beaucoup
de produits liés au lindworm au ver de
tatouage et vous pouvez voir le stylo
c'est sur le T-shirt donc si on va plus loin
on peut voir la légende c'est écrit dans un
joli livre et on peut voir le blason
de kragenfoot avec  arrière-plan en duo avec la
tour blanche c'est comme une marque que vous
connaissez pour que
vous puissiez aller plus loin c'est aussi pour les enfants
vous avez le livre sur le dragon il est
décrit comme un dragon ici Souvenirs
d'un petit enfant c'est très agréable
de vous emmener à  ton lit dors et pour
le chapeau Spotify
[Music] [
Music]
est
[Music]
livraison
Je pense que c'est la combinaison la
combinaison est la ville le lac
et le gland je ne peux pas dire qu'une
personne vient à l'horloge et au pied uniquement
pour  voir la salle des glands et une personne
vient à kragenfoot uniquement pour aller
nager dans le lac c'est la combinaison de ce que la
nourriture clagan offre
[Musique]
étranger
et nous avons le ver à peluches dans notre nom
car c'est un symbole pour clangfoot  et
notre restaurant est vraiment proche de la
stature du lintworm
hoof boy est une chaîne de restaurants où vous
pouvez manger et boire de la nourriture typique de Munich
et oui j'ai travaillé dans un cabinet dentaire parce que
c'est aussi typique des vidéos de Munich
[Music]
donc en fait le monstre peut être vivant
parce que comme certains il y a quelques mois, il y a eu
une histoire très étrange, il y a eu
des gars peut-être ivres et ouais ce qu'ils ont
fait, c'est qu'ils pensaient que le monstre
était vivant et alors ils ont essayé de
le réparer non ils ont grimpé sur le monstre
sur le  la queue et la queue se sont cassées,
nous avons donc dû la réparer à nouveau, c'était un
cauchemar plus ou moins pour le lindworm
et pour ces gars à coup sûr
étrangers
[Music]
là-bas, vous ne pouvez pas être si sûr et
quand vous nagez, vous nagez bien
dans le lac et vous allez plus loin,
vous pourriez toucher quelque chose et vous n'êtes pas
sûr que ce soit le lindworm, alors
parfois vous ne pouvez pas avoir peur disons que
comme cette
importance économique,
de nombreux touristes viennent ici pour voir le
relief parce que  cela rend Langford un
peu intéressant parce qu'ils veulent
connaître l'histoire de la salle des peluches
et veulent la voir
[Musique]
quand je serai plus grand et que j'aurai des enfants, je
leur raconterai l'histoire de la salle des terres
mais je ne veux pas  qu'ils aient peur
Atticus
[Musique]
le boom Tesla a aussi quelque chose de
spécial et de chaleureux
comment dire de l'énergie
[Musique]
eh bien si vous voulez vraiment vraiment voir un
bar à tatouages ​​alors je vous donne le conseil
d'abord boire du schnaps qui est très
courant  ici dans la région alpine, alors
quand il est tard dans la nuit,
commencez à gravir les montagnes à travers
quelques petites rivières et écoutez
peut-être que vous l'entendez
et je parie que vous aurez peur et
c'est le verbe titre
[Musique]
malgré tout mon scepticisme concernant le
toucher  de pièce que vous ne pouvez jamais, il serait
très imprudent d'exclure en fait 100
qu'il y a quelque chose comme le tatouage
chaud, c'est très peu probable, mais qui sait
et même si vous ne rencontrez pas de
pièce tactile, je suis à peu près certain que le
paysage sur le  montagnes
um de Corinthe vaudront bien la
visite avec ou sans une touche d'une
observation
[Musique]
étrangère